what is the best Shrek film the first
one Jinx you owe me a coke
double triple jins you ow me three
[Music]
Co how do you two think you're going to
fair at this do you reckon there's going
to be a lot of arguments I don't think
we're going to argue I think I'm just
going to straight up he's going to I
feel like Mark you might be very
agreeable this I'll gladly do it I'll
sacrifice myself for your show but we've
made it we've made it very clear to each
other we love each other and this is for
the game we have to we have to be mean
okay
ready what if we agree on what if we
agree on would be adorable Ginger Spice
is the superior spice
go we didn't even have to get the whole
question up I'm GNA excuse me I'm going
to move one up because Ginger Spice is
incredible to choose a superior Spice
Girl is INS insane my favorite growing
up was always Baby Spice but to choose
one above of the all five it's not it's
not even fair
no thank you I'll move over to disagree
with you okay we'll turn the cameras off
here do you secretly have a favorite
listen you can have a favorite without
oh Posh Spice is your favorite yeah
really B like that's a
lot that's a lot about you
okay I believe in all things you can
have a favorite a personal favorite
without saying they're
Superior so maybe we just go to neutral
yeah oh my God we agree on everything
we're best
friends we already knew that as best
friends what do you think the other
person's spice goals Persona would be
Hulk spice spy spice Sporty Spice are
you
insane no you're Posh Spice I am kind of
yeah oh God that's so rude I know who
are you of the five yeah you're all five
mixed into one stop it all
spice you're my little all
spice we're we're all facets of all of
them we're multifaceted we're
multifaceted we have five sides that's
right or maybe more agreeing has never
been so much fun on this show yeah we
we're not calling it agree to disree
it's just agree naked attraction is the
greatest TV show in
existence I mean how beat nak how do you
beat that how do you get so many
contestants that's what I want to know I
mean so and it's like a teacher oh yeah
lawyer you're like waa yeah it's amazing
so great oh the music teacher that lady
oh that was a while ago I can't believe
you remember that that's awesome yeah
yeah there's really there's really a a
lot of great stuff going on the guy with
the um elephant
tattoo I don't remember the elephant
tattoo on his leg
[Laughter]
no no not not on his leg no cuz it was
on his
arm elephant oh no anyway greatest show
for our us audience can you two just
explain what naked attraction is naked
attraction is a game show in the UK
effectively a game show but it's a
dating show pry where there's one
contestant that comes out and then
there's five contestants that are Behind
These sort of panels and then in each
round they sort of reveal more of their
bodies they're not they're naked they're
fully naked fully naked and then you get
to you know they start eliminating
People based on like just you know
genitalia then it goes up to like you
know chest whatever then you see their
face and then they can say something and
then they choose to go on a date and
they all they're naked the the
person to get for the they've all seen
each other naked and they do these kind
of like naked hugs and then they go on a
proper date yes and most of them end
disastrous yeah most of them are not are
not what about the old couple where the
lady's like he never he never messaged
me back he's like what are you talking
about of course I did she's like he's
lying he's like that's
I've never seen the shot
making totally make all pretty good
though would you like to see that one I
would love that brussel sprouts get too
much
hate I love brussels sprouts so much I
love Brussels I made Brussels sprout
brussels sprouts I made brussels sprouts
we had um a Thanksgiving in Budapest
when we were shooting um p and uh Mark
made his famous Brussels sprouts and
they were excellent thank you we love
brussel sprouts yes they were pine nuts
in there pine nuts Sprouts yeah yeah you
little devil thank
you what an interesting thing in the
morning yeah I know they have a little
butter on them oh they do mhm okay mhm
how do these compare to Marks they're a
little Bland no offense but marks are
better but these are good I took a bit
of offense to that I'm not going to lie
you had
coming you are I thought you two are
meant to be fighting not us no no this
is
everybody you better put your uh your
rain coats on because the spray is
coming right we might take the spray out
now you have these later it's all good
thank
you baths are just a fancy way of
swimming in your own filth oh oh damn it
we both like baths okay all right
another one the world does does not need
a new Shrek
[Laughter]
film and we don't want to comment on
that back to
neutral thank you next what but real
talk what is the best Shrek film The
Jinx you owe me a coke
double triple Jinx you ow me three
C
there's no winning with
you we need to disagree on something we
will oh don't worry give us something
more controversial being a friend Super
Fan is the worst personality
tra
friends is
excellent that's the best Personality
yeah we did that we did that whole
trivia night no everybody loves friends
here well you don't really know friends
as
most you're just trying to argue I am I
don't I don't really know friends I have
no
friends I don't really know you know who
an amazing who knows everything about
friends yosl Theos he's seen every
episode every episode you can quiz him
like Mark and yoris and I went out to
dinner a couple weeks ago and and during
it I was like Mark watch this and then I
got up a whole trivia website and and
asked Yos like every question about
friends and you couldn't believe it
yorgos Lanos who made killing of a
sacred deer and dog to and dog Tu is
obsessed with friends is obsessed with
friends it's true it's the most like
it's adorable mindblowing is it's
adorable
it's um Mark you said you haven't really
seen friends can you give us a a summary
of what you think it is it's a show
about some friends well done let's go
yeah nice thank you you crush that I
just pulled that out of my ass of it I
mean not all of it eating McDonald's
abroad is a must
do oh you don't actually feel that way I
had McDonald's every other day when we
were in
hungry I got you McDonald's
hungry I I forgot I forgot I forgot I
forgot he's right he did get me
McDonald's and hungry I do want to try
McDonald's everywhere McDonald's and
hungry so good because they kill they
have to kill the animal within like 10
miles of the McDonald's so it's Super
Fresh the fries in McDonald's inung God
the McFlurry I feel like you got me an
minin McFlurry as well many of them
friend you're my best friend Emily
Emma my real my real name is Emily he
knows my name I always have to make that
clear Emily
blonde people are like her name's not
Emily you're like oh buddy if you only
saw her bir so divic good what is your
go-to McDonald's order mine is so
depressing what is it it's all you like
cheese like a plain burger it's number
two two cheeseburgers but I without the
cheese any my 12year old I know I know I
eat like a 12-year-old it's like a it's
just the meat and the bun the fries a Dr
Pepper or a Coke depending on the day
and then a mcf flurry yeah what's yours
a quarter pound or with cheese no onions
damn why no onions they give me gas
okay it's not for me it's for everyone
around me it's like an act of
kindness if I'm by myself double onions
cool non-stop entertainment for the next
hours sorry this is really blue humor
well I think that's it guys so thank you
agree I really wanted to fight with you
but it's so hard to fight with you
you're so adorable you're so adorable
you can just have a scrap up in the
corridor if you won I'm going to kick
her ass now that was a lot of suppressed
rage how many more of these do we have
we've got 97 more no we don't I'm
sorry what happen
drink oh wow we're really going hard
yeah that was exciting even the light
bulb couldn't handle that
fire nice dance should we DST out our
dance
yeah